[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue dans ce nouveau numéro
de 7,8 échos le magazine consacré à
l'actualité économique de notre
territoire sans plus tarder voici le
sommaire
nous nous intéresserons aux nouveaux
modes d'organisation de travail depuis
ces dernières années de nouveaux lieux
comme les espaces de travail partagés se
sont multipliées sur le territoire de
saint quentin en yvelines
une mutation qui n'est pas sans
conséquences sur l'immobilier
d'entreprise
à quoi ressembleront les bureaux de
demain frédérique miquel directeur
associé du cabinet car dame nous en dira
plus focus sur une jeune start-up
versaillaise qui l'on sera dans quelques
semaines sa propre marque de lunettes
prémontées vite vu bienvenue a choisi
d'allier design matériaux naturels et
prix attractifs enfin nous ferons un
point sur le reste de l'actualité
économique dans les yvelines avec
notamment des entreprises yvelinoise
championne de la croissance ou encore
une start up basée à guyancourt qui
propose un réseau social privé pour les
entreprises
m mais avant de développer tous et y
trouveront ce magazine avec un chiffre
cinq mille c'est le nombre d'offres
d'emploi dans le numérique recenser ces
six derniers mois à saint quentin en
yvelines et des offres qui ne sont pas
toutes satisfaites en raison des
difficultés pour les entreprises à
recruter et c'est pourquoi une
convention de partenariat vient d'être
signé entre l'agglomération et sept
organismes proposant des formations
liées au numérique
treize formations qui bénéficie du label
sky école du numérique direction
versailles à présent où une jeune start
up est sur le point de lancer sa propre
marque de lunettes prémontées
la gamme vite vu bienvenue sera
disponible au prix de 39 euros et sera
bientôt distribuée dans les pharmacies
mais aussi chez des opticiens reportage
réunion hebdomadaire pour l'équipe de
vie de vue bien vu à quelques semaines
du lancement de cette nouvelle marque de
lunettes versaillaise l'heure est aux
derniers ajustements pour cette jeune
start up imaginé il ya un peu plus de
deux ans cette gamme de lunettes
prémontées propose notamment des verts
multivision en fait en eau du fleuve
nous avons envers qui va être ici sans
correction est en bas du verre vous
allez avoir un verre comme sur des prêts
montée avec une correction de plus une
plusieurs ce qui permet d'utiliser
saynètes tout temps pour voir aussi bien
de loin que de près l'équipe composée en
partie d'opticiens a misé sur des
matériaux naturels
les lunettes sont composées
majoritairement de coton un matériau
durable dans le temps c'est ce qui a
notamment séduit les designers c'est
avec quelque chose qui nous intéressait
aussi énormément dans ce projet c'est
d'être sur quelque chose de qualitatif
est aussi un matériau qui est beaucoup
plus intéressant que de faire un énième
une énième pré montées en plastique
injecté
c'est important pour nous d'être sur ce
matériau qui est un très beau matériaux
et qu'on n'utilise pas assez on a
constaté que le secteur de l'optique
aujourd'hui est un secteur en pleine
mutation
on a des nouvelles normes législatives
avec la loi amont des remboursements au
niveau des mutuelles qui diminue on sait
que le pouvoir d'achat haut niveau et
des français aujourd'hui est faible et
les coûts optiques sont assez élevés
donc l'idée c'est vraiment de proposer
ce produit qualitatif un prix à moins de
40 euros pour justement répondre à un
vrai besoin au niveau de la population
en plus des verts multivision vie du
bien vu propose également des verts qui
protègent de la lumière bleue renvoyé
par certains appareils numériques 18
modèles seront disponibles au printemps
prochain sur un site internet dédié mais
aussi chez des opticiens et des
pharmacies partenaires dans les yvelines
et à paris ouvre à présent le dossier de
ce numéro consacré aux nouveaux modes
d'organisation de travail depuis ces
dernières années le travail collaboratif
les espaces de travail partagés ou
encore le télétravail se sont
développées une évolution qui n'est pas
sans conséquences sur l'immobilier
d'entreprise
comme vous allez le voir à travers ce
reportage se rendre tous les jours dans
un lieu déterminé pour exercer son
activité professionnelle
ce mode de fonctionnement est voué dans
quelques années à disparaître avec
l'apparition de nouveaux modes de
travail
exemple avec les espaces de coworking
depuis ces dernières années ses bureaux
partagés ont fleuri un peu partout à
saint quentin en yvelines
une formule qui semble séduire puisque
l'ancien stop and work s'implantera le
19 mars prochain à montigny le
bretonneux
en 18 ans m
une département qui est extrêmement
actif un bassin économique est très
dynamique et saint quentin en yvelines
et à couler de source
ça faisait un petit moment que je
regardais sur le secteur de trouver la
bonne opportunité
pas trop loin de la gare pas trop loin
du centre ville et donc ça s'est
présentée on n'a pas hésité une seconde
164 postes de travail seront répartis
sur 1000 mètres carrés des espaces
destinés aussi bien aux chefs
d'entreprises cotées les travailleurs
ont ça va de la personne qui peut qui a
besoin de louer une salle de réunion où
des bureaux de temps en temps de façon
ponctuelle pour recevoir des clients
pensent qu'il peut pas le faire à son
domicile ou pour économiser les
transports à des gens qui vont
s'installer de façon plus pérenne sur un
mois deux mois trois mois un an deux ans
mais là aussi on sait les accompagner
sur la durée une mutation des modes de
travail qui n'est pas sans conséquences
sur l'immobilier d'entreprise à saint
quentin en yvelines
malgré une année 2010 est riche en
transactions il est nécessaire
aujourd'hui d'adapter cette ressource
il faut que les immeubles soient
complètement rénové et restructuré voir
démolir ou reconstruits pour s'adapter
justement à ces nouveaux modes
d'organisation du travail avec des
espaces complètement différent plus du
tout de bureaux individuels comme comme
avant pour incarner ces nouveaux modes
de travail le groupe crédit agricole
située à guyancourt s'est lancé il ya
quelques années dans un ambitieux
programme immobilier avec la création
d'un campus le skypark objectif
principal préserver la qualité de vie au
travail
ça rejoint les valeurs mutualistes et
humaines du groupe crédit agricole qui
notamment
est-ce que plus on est dans un
environnement agréable et respectueux
bien effectivement mieux on travaille
avec 5000 personnes qui travaillent sur
le campus notamment dans le domaine
technologique surtout dans le domaine
technologique
on a besoin de recruter chaque année à
peu près 1000 personnes c'est absolument
considérable et 1000 personnes de très
haut niveau donc naturellement on
souhaite que venir travailler à skypark
souhaite un must et que naturellement ce
soit avec plaisir que des candidats se
présentent pour les recrutements que
nous réalisons travail et bien-être
deux notions qui semble indissociable de
notions auxquelles vont devoir s'adapter
les entreprises
alors à quoi ressembleront les
entreprises et les bureaux de demain
éléments de réponse avec frédérique
miquel directeur associé du groupe car
dame
il était présent le 15 février dernier à
guyancourt à l'occasion du rendez vous
des acteurs de l'immobilier d'entreprise
frédérique miquel bonjour bonjour vous
êtes directeur associé du groupe car
d'amalur car dame c'est une société qui
accompagne les entreprises dans leurs
projets de construction de
réhabilitation et d'aménagement
est ce que vous pouvez dans un premier
temps nous en dire plus sur vos
différentes activités justement oui
alors nous faisons aussi du conseil
parce qu'en amont de tous ces projets il
ya du conseil nous sommes consultants
nous sommes architectes nous sommes
aménageurs
nous travaillons aussi bien pour les
utilisateurs le preneur à bail que pour
les propriétaires ou les investisseurs
qui veulent mener un projet intéressant
rentable sur l'ensemble de la france
dans son ensemble de la france
absolument et puis quelques périphérie
européenne
est-ce que vous pouvez nous citer déjà
quelques exemples de réalisations
peut-être en ile de france je sais pas
peut-être ici à saint quentin en
yvelines ou du mans en ile-de-france
alors nous avons
nous avons travaillé sur souvent des
projets dans des grands groupes donc par
exemple en ce moment où travaillant sur
le projet de capgemini sur l'île de
france
ont pu travailler sur des projets comme
des grands
les projets total à la défense des
choses comme ça ces dernières années on
a remarqué un que l'immobilier
d'entreprise ce était on va dire modifié
en raison des nouveaux modes de travail
comment vous vous expliquer cette
évolution
je pense que il y à une prise de
conscience depuis quelques temps mais
c'est assez récent quant au fait que
l'immobilier peut devenir un vrai levier
à la fois de la performance économique
de l'entreprise mais également de la
performance managériale
organisationnelle de l'entreprise c'est
un levier pour améliorer et optimiser
son compte d'exploitation c'est un
levier pour améliorer l'engagement de
ses équipes faire en sorte qu'en fait la
performance de l'équipe au travail soit
meilleur alors justement qu'est ce que
vous demande les entreprises
aujourd'hui il y a
une grande réflexion sur la notion de
bien-être au travail
là aussi ce lien a été créée récemment
la conviction que un collaborateur qui
est satisfait de son environnement de
travail qui est satisfait des services
que lui propose son entreprise sur son
lieu de travail sera un collaborateur à
la fois puis fidèle et sera un
collaborateur plus efficace et daniel
qu'est-ce qui est mis en place justement
pour ce bien et beaucoup beaucoup de
services c'est en train d'arriver les
premiers services historiques des
services de conciergerie un peu comme ce
que vous trouvez dans les hôtels
maintenant ça va bien au delà 1 et
beaucoup d espace si on parle de la
configuration architecturale
beaucoup d'espèces qui sont des espaces
collaboratifs toujours des espaces
ouverts mais où on va en fait se
déplacer dans l'espace pour passer d'une
activité à une autre au cours de la
journée il par exemple plus très bon
fonctionnement du cerveau de faire
fonctionner ses jambes donc des espaces
qui sont collaboratifs et des espaces
qui sont extrêmement de technologie
qu'il vient ce sera ça sera également
l'avenir donc ça ça marche il faut de la
technologie dans l'est
justement faut parler d'avenir on va se
projeter dans quelques années finalement
à quoi vont ressembler les bureaux dans
le futur moi je pense que les bureaux
dans le futur d'abord vont être multi
vous n'aurez plus un seul bureau vous
aurez plusieurs lieux de travail
le premier étant chez vous et puis après
des tirs lieu espace de coworking
c'est comme ça qu'on les appelle
aujourd'hui et puis enfin votre le siège
de votre entreprise le bureau de votre
entreprise au minimum pour ce qui
concerne le bureau de votre entreprise
ça devrait être en ligne où vous avez du
plaisir à vous rendre et en particulier
dans une grande conurbation communes de
france vers le problème de transport à
caen ce qu'ils sont pour vous y rendre y
rendre et moins souvent
d'autres fois vous restera la maison de
thé le travail vous serez dans des
espaces de coworking mais quand vous
rendrez mans au siège de votre
entreprise
il faut que ça soit un bon moment et un
bon moment c'est quoi les lieux sont
agréables les lieux vous accueillent
bien les lieux vous reconnaissent ils
sont agréables dans la forme sont
agréables dans le confort qu'ils vous
procurer sont agréables aussi parce que
c'est un espace de socialisation
l'espace de travail de demain sera un
espace de socialisation
en fait la question de la connaissance
de l'expertisé n'est plus vraiment une
question dans les sociétés occidentales
bien vous avez toute la connaissance du
monde
autre de votre main grâce à google les
engloutit la question c'est comment est
ce que vous allez l'utiliser vous allez
l'utilisent en interagissant avec les
autres vous allez utiliser par votre
capacité de socialisation supérieur
c'est ça que devront produire les
les lieux de travail de demain merci à
frédéric amical pour cette analyse je
rappelle qu'au bled directeur associé du
groupe car d'amertume 150000 euros pour
l'opération budget participatif à
maurepas une start up qui propose un
réseau social privé pour les organismes
mais aussi des entreprises chinoises
championnes de croissance s'est tout de
suite dans l'économie en bref le journal
les echos a publié son nouveau palmarès
des champions de la croissance
parmi les 500 entreprises les plus
dynamiques certaines sont implantés dans
les yvelines
c'est le cas de fraude buster à vélizy
l'entreprise proposant des services de
détection de fraude à des opérateurs
télécoms et 28e avec un taux de
croissance de plus 110 9 points 7 % en
bonne position également aux oem dit fan
service sise à elancourt spécialisé dans
la vente de biens et services sur la
maintenance d'appareils militaires
l'entreprise et 65e avec un taux de
croissance de + 85,9 % permettre aux
collaborateurs d'une entreprise ou d'une
collectivité de communiquer plus
facilement grâce à un réseau social
privé
c'est ce que composent net frame une
start-up installé à guyancourt une
solution pour travailler de manière
collaborative stocker des documents ou
encore jerry des projets on a développé
ce produit plutôt à destination des
organisations sert des structures qui
sont éclaté géographiquement et qui ont
besoin de se retrouver autour d'un
espace même s'il est virtuel mais qui
permet néanmoins de bien de mettre en
place des des groupes projets des
groupes de travail qui vont se retrouver
sur cette plateforme digitale pour la
troisième année consécutive la ville de
maurepas lançons opération budget
participatif et d'habitants ont jusqu'au
12 mars pour proposer un projet qu'il
souhaite voir réaliser mobilité
aménagements sport ou encore culture le
budget alloué est de 150000 euros
l'année dernière trois projets
plébiscité par les mort pas y ont été
réalisés aménagement d'hôtels à insectes
rénovation d'une aire de jeux et
création d'un stricte work out
avant de se quitter quelques rendez vous
économiques qui vous attend le mardi 6
mars closky cuba guyancourt organise un
petit déjeuner intitulé booster paris
saclay export c'est de 8h30 à 10h
inscription au 01 39 30 51 30
et puis si vous êtes une entreprise et
que vous avez besoin de recrutement
et bien vous pouvez vous inscrire à
l'événement en piste pour l'emploi qui
aura lieu le jeudi 29 mars de 10h à 22h
un site internet www.skype.com voilà
c'est la fin de ce numéro merci de
l'avoir suivi on se retrouve mardi 6
mars pour un nouveau 7,8 échos à très
bientôt
[Musique]